Maddi you've always been my choice Oh
Abbi
looks like playing favorites wasn't a
good idea after all if you only had
treated everyone the same then maybe
Maddie Ziegler wouldn't have left the
ALDC and never lips back we all make
mistakes though so don't beat yourself
up about it
Maddie's a star and she's got Dance Moms
to thank for it we're happy to know that
you're learning from your mistakes why
else would you send a brady home season
eight of Dance Moms plays by a different
set of rules Abby Lee Miller isn't the
same person she used to be and she's
done playing favorites
Maddie's shot to stardom has definitely
affected her former dance teacher watch
until the end to find out why Abby is
done putting all her eggs into one
lonely basket there's nothing like
watching your favorite student become
one of the most popular dancers in
America well unless you're Abby Lee
Miller that is Maddie Ziegler rise to
fame is bittersweet for her former dance
teacher because well she doesn't get to
share her success
Maddie grew up in front of the camera
and became a household name thanks to
the reality TV series Dance Moms today
she's a superstar who is known for
dancing in seus videos as well as being
a brand promoter actress model and
celebrity judge Abby's former dancer is
on fire and she's got fans for days but
why on earth is Maddie's fame suddenly
affecting Abby's behavior but now I just
have so much weight off my shoulders I'm
like oh I can just live my life
well for starters Abby Lee Miller feels
betrayed she spent over a decade by
Maddie's side teaching her how to dance
and pushing her to be her best but once
Maddie made the choice to leave Dance
Moms she totally turned her back on Abby
while the dancer definitely had her
reasons and valid ones at that
Abby truly loves Maddie and thought that
Maddie felt the same Maddie's betrayal
hit a be hard especially after finding
out that Maddie didn't even include her
in her tell-all book the Maddie Diaries
instead Maddie praised her new mentor
SIA and threw shade Abby's way without
ever mentioning her name
ouch that's gotta hurt I don't really
think I have anything to say about her
if feeling betrayed wasn't bad enough
Abbey also feels forgotten by her former
dancer according to Us Weekly Maddie and
Abby's relationship didn't end with a
big blowout instead Abby got ghosted
after the Ziegler sisters chose to leave
Dance Moms Abby's life took a turn for
the worse she faced a handful of
lawsuits was prosecuted and jailed and
then diagnosed with a life-threatening
ailments but Maddie never reached out or
visited Abby in the hospital this was
heartbreaking for Abby Lee Miller who
takes great pride in her relationships
with her students so we're not too
surprised to see Abby switching things
up in season eight of Dance Moms we see
you as a tough lady that's a different
type of tough Abby isn't the easiest
person to work with which is why her
students and their mothers have often
cut all contact with her but at the end
of the day Abby's a fantastic teacher
who goes the extra mile in retrospect
Abby regrets everything but she hasn't
apologized for her actions instead she
feels like she's responsible for
Maddie's success while it's true that
Maddie got her start on Dance Moms and
shot to fame soon after she doesn't Oh
Abby anything and she's proven this by
cutting her out of her life in a perfect
world Abby should be sharing 90 success
but unfortunately that's just not the
case not being a part of Maddie's
success hit Abby real hard
she's talked about this at many
interviews and we know exactly where she
stands but we never once thought that
this would change the way she went about
teaching her future students back in the
day Abby was quick to ridicule her
students and praised Maddie in front of
everyone since Maddie was clearly one of
her most talented dancers Abby didn't
see anything wrong with parading her
left right and center it was a
well-known fact that Maddie was Abby's
favorite and it made people jealous not
only did it drive the Dance Moms insane
with jealousy but it also heard
everyone's self-esteem and once the
Ziegler sisters chose to leave the show
Abby strong foundation began to crumble
each one of you are just another number
easily replaceable yet somehow this just
wasn't the case for Maddie
putting Maddie on a pedestal was the
wrong move and now that Maddie won't
speak to her Abby knows she has to
switch things up not only did playing
favorites cause Abby to lose her prize
dancer but it also made the other girls
feel
left out so when a better opportunity
came around they jumped ship instead of
being loyal to Abby they left her
hanging Nia Kendall Kalani and Cameron
left the ALDC to compete with another
studio at the fierce national dance
competition without ever looking back
so while Abby says that all of her
dancers are replaceable
she's also realized that every dance
teacher is replaceable as well and let's
just say that she's not going to make
the same mistake twice season eight of
Dance Moms is nothing like the reality
TV show used to be instead of playing
favorites Abby is trying to bring all of
her dancers to new heights
Abby has realized that when one dancer
is better than everyone else the other
dancers rely on them to carry the show
so she's playing a very different hand
too this time around
Abby's confirmed that nobody is safe not
even the group's the best dancer and
only boy
Brady Farrar this talented young dancer
was shocked when he got sent home during
the season fifth episode but after
facing a losing streak Abby has chosen
to change a per game plan the old Abby
would have praised Brady and criticized
her other dancers but thanks to Maddie's
fame Abby knows that putting all her
eggs in one basket is the worst thing
she can do for the ALDC so what do you
guys think about Abby's decision to send
Brady home let us know in the comment
section below and that's a wrap give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]